and more here's a look
we're coming this morning less than 24
hours after yesterday's
act of terror we wanted to organize
a briefing for you with the information
that we have
the mayor is here uh the members of our
congressional delegation
all of the law enforcement leadership we
have several people who want to present
uh to you this morning and take your
questions a couple points i want to i
want to mention at the outset
uh i told you yesterday that the fbi
has taken charge of the investigation
special agent in charge rick delaurier
will speak um shortly it's important to
clarify
that two and only two explosive devices
were found yesterday other parcels all
other parcels in the area of the blast
have been
examined but there are no unexploded
bombs there were no unexploded explosive
devices
found over 150 people were injured
yesterday in the in the blast some
gravely our thoughts go out to all of
those injured
and killed uh and to their families and
friends
i personally want to thank the
extraordinary uh
first responders for their uh just
extraordinary work yesterday
every single one of them those who were
on site and those who got
to the site promptly thereafter
performed beautifully as have
the area hospitals and i've been calling
around to the heads of the hospitals
personally to thank them as well it's
our hope that
tomorrow we will organize an interfaith
prayer service to help our community
heal we don't have details on that yet
but we will
provide those details when we when we
have them there is a support center
that was opened yesterday in what we
call the castle
opposite the park plaza hotel on
arlington and stewart street i think it
is the mayor
and his uh has provided staff
to help people cope with uh with
this extraordinary event and it will be
open from nine i think until five
o'clock or beyond uh
this evening finally everyone should
expect
continued heightened police presence and
everyone should continue
personally to be vigilant the
investigation continues
and until it is done all of those
in law enforcement represented by the
leaders here will be
present in force in the area around the
blast and throughout the city and with
that let me turn it over to mayor menino
uh thank you governor yesterday the
terror was brought to uh
the city of boston tragedy was brought
to one of our neighborhoods also
this is a close-knit place the city of
boston here we know our neighbors
we grieve for them we grief a little boy
who we knew from
dorchester but also today i want to say
we know our heroes also they are the men
and women
who wear helmets where the badgers the
runners
who helped us yesterday during this uh
time of need and as we get go together
on this issue with all the law
enforcement officials
we're gonna make sure the city pulls
together you know we got it under
control
let's continue to work together let's
keep offering a helping hand
to individuals who may need it during
this uh very difficult time
in our city's history but i just say to
all of you i've
a mayor for 20 years now i've never seen
law enforcement pull together working
together to solve our crime and our city
as they have
but also how people pull together the
business community the neighbors
everyone
this is a tragedy but boston's a strong
city
we're seeing they'll get through this
and uh like the governor said we set up
a uh
resource center over at the castle near
uh
the park plaza hotel where staff will be
there available to give
information to individuals who've been
involved in the marathon
it's open from nine to five and the
phone number is uh
let me think about our phone number six
three five five oh four
i believe and uh in our hotline at city
numbers wrong number 617-534-505-0
and also the 24-hour hotline that you
need
need information also that number is
617-635
and over the last several hours we've
received calls from
all over the world asking us information
about the uh
our tragedy and how they can help us uh
so this is a
bad day for boston but i think that if
you pull together we'll get through it
we're strong so a lot of people willing
to work together to make this a better
place for all our people and so as we
gather here today
with all our officials let's say boston
will overcome
thank you mr mayor senator thank you
thank you governor thank you mr mayor um
the president of the united states has
pledged his full support
in all efforts both to keep the city
safe and to find the person who did this
and bring them to justice
we did not have to reach out to the
president the president reached out to
us
he called the governor he called the
mayor he called the members of the
delegation
because the president is actively
involved here in responding
on behalf of our congressional
delegation senator cowan is here with me
and congressman lynch
and all of the members of our delegation
we want to extend our thanks to the
first responders to the firefighters to
the police officers
to the ems to everyone on the scene
including the volunteers
who came and helped those in trouble and
helped save lives we also
want to thank those from all around the
country and all around the world
whose prayers and thoughts and offers of
help have poured in
we are deeply grateful as the mayor says
boston will survive
okay
thank you governor good morning my name
is rick delaurier i'm the special agent
in charge of the fbi's boston division
i would like to start this morning by
thanking the first responders from
boston ems and boston fire department
and the volunteer physicians
nurses and medical staff from the
community have volunteered at the
marathon
their services and heroic actions saved
lives yesterday afternoon
we continue to work shoulder to shoulder
with our jttf partners at the boston
police department
the massachusetts state police as well
as all our other jttf agencies
our mission is clear to bring to justice
those responsible for the marathon
bombing
the american public wants answers the
citizens of the city of boston and the
commonwealth of massachusetts want and
deserve
answers this group of dedicated men and
women standing for you today
pledged to do everything possible to get
those answers
this remains a very active investigation
our ongoing investigation in various
locations throughout the area goes on
however there are no known additional
threats we continue to interview various
witnesses
and process the crime scene which could
take some time
the citizens of massachusetts and the
city of boston should expect to see the
fbi and its jttf partners
conducting investigative activity in the
greater eastern massachusetts and boston
area
assistance from the public remains
critical in establishing a timeline of
events
which leads to swift conclusion through
due diligence and strong investigative
activity
we commend the public we commend the
citizens of boston and the
citizens of the commonwealth of
massachusetts for the information that
has been provided to law enforcement
so far and we strongly encourage that uh
assistance to continue it is paramount
to explain the fbi and our jttf role
to a greater extent the volume of tips
we have received
in reiterating the resources we provide
we have received voluminous tips over
the last
18 hours since the since the incident we
have staffed our eight 1 800 call fbi
tip line and we continue to encourage
individuals to contact that line with
any additional tips
we are bringing additional victim
assistance and evidence response team
resources
from our headquarters components and
other field offices to boston and they
are on site
working as we speak processing evidence
at the crime scene
to the extent that the crime scene still
plays in copley perimeter and it
continues to be a crime scene it may be
that for several days
the fbi jttf is logically following up
on a variety of leads
you will see us in our law enforcement
partners interviewing maybe your
neighbor or co-worker or even yourself
in coming
days we encourage you to please
cooperate with law enforcement
authorities
the resources the fbi and the jttf allow
for
swift action which you hope will yield
quick results but that does not diminish
our diligence
and persistence and combing through the
high volume of evidence and leads
that we are processing right now we are
just beginning upon that path
thank you very much
i'm a yes i'm gene marquez acting
special agent charge
atf boston field division at this time
atf has done a partial
nrt national response team activation we
are bringing our explosive specialists
here to the scene and we will be working
jointly with the fbi
and its partners on the jttf we have
certified explosive specialists
we have explosives enforcement officers
we have special agent bomb techs and we
have canines
that are trained to detect any explosive
devices
or any residue at this time we have
approximately
30 forensic specialists enroute are on
the scene
and to dispel any rumors there were
there were rumors floating around that
there were seven devices up to seven
devices at one point
that is not true i think that that
happened as a result of some device
some suspect packages that were
disrupted
uh but we only have two devices that
we're aware of and both
of those devices were the ones that
involved in the that did the damage and
were involved in the in the explosives
incident at this time we are looking for
the public's cooperation we're looking
if there's any video
any photographic evidence if you can
please contact the fbi hotline
or the city's hotline we'd like to
review any kind of media that you have
out there
uh pretending that that might give us
additional investigative leads and we
are pursuing those investigative leads
at this time
the scene is going to take several days
to process we'll just ask for your
patience as we're working in that area
and for your cooperation
good morning i'm united states attorney
carmen ortiz
first i i want to extend my condolences
to the families of the loved ones
who were lost in yesterday's attack on
the city of boston
as well as those that were hurt and may
still be fighting for their lives
our thoughts and our prayers are go out
to them what happened yesterday was a
terrible tragedy
yet it was amazing to see as you have
heard from my colleagues here
uh how people uh just helped one another
ran toward the blast just to assist
another person in greater
need people who um were just uh
there for those that were hurt uh and in
a dire situation
it was amazing to see how the city of
boston the peop and people from around
the world
that were part of yesterday's boston
marathon
helped one another consoled each other
there are
so many moving parts to an investigation
such as this
and i can't begin to thank everyone who
has been involved
law enforcement medical professionals
emergency
responders and really just regular
citizens who
became heroes yesterday i want to repeat
as i did stated yesterday
this is an active and it's an ongoing
investigation
but rest assured that we are bringing
all of the necessary resources to assist
in this matter and that we will conduct
all that we can with all of our law
enforcement partners
i've been in touch with the attorney
general several times eric holder
and he has pledged all the resource from
the department
and others on behalf of the federal
government to help boston recover
from yesterday i ask for your patience
and your understanding
as we continue to pursue leads to gather
evidence and to get to the bottom
of who did this and why thank you
thank you
good morning my name is ed davis i'm a
police commissioner for the city of
boston
we are in the process of securing and
processing the most complex crime scene
that we've dealt with in the history of
our department
we are doing that under the direction of
the fbi and in partnership
with the atf we've secured the perimeter
with members of the national guard and
the general is here
i'd like to thank the people who are
working closely with us
we've received office for of assistance
from chicago los angeles
units have responded here from new york
city and baltimore
and we are working very closely with all
of our partners on this
complex investigation i um
i want to stress that the area around
the crime scene
which was yesterday was 15 blocks has
been reduced
to about 12 blocks at this point in time
and we will continue to collapse that
crime scene
as the facts and circumstances make that
available we want to
open up as many streets and and get
people into their buildings as quickly
as we can we're working diligently on
that
but please be patient with us uh in the
time that we need to process the crime
scene we expect that that scene
will go for another two days anyway and
people should make appropriate plans
again i want to stress that any
information that you have any videos of
photographs
that happen not just at that scene but
anywhere in the in the immediate
vicinity
could be helpful to this investigation
our focus
is on processing that evidence right now
and we're looking forward to working
with our
with our partners uh to bring the
individuals who are responsible for this
heinous crime to uh to justice
thank you commissioner
good morning my name is timothy albin
i'm the superintendent of the
massachusetts state police
as i said earlier in one of our
briefings there's really
two or three parts to this investigation
there's the investigative part which
clearly the fbi has taken the lead on
but there's also
a logistical and presence
component of this so i'm speaking to the
public
you are going to see an enhanced
presence from
the boston police from the state police
from the national guard and from our law
enforcement partners through the
metropolitan boston
area over the next days and probably
longer that's not for any particular
reason other than to provide some
comfort and to the public who are using
transportation centers or going about
their business
so we are engaged with the mbta police
uh in the t you will see more troopers
you'll see national guardsmen there
you'll see mbta police like you do every
day
but that presence will be significantly
enhanced
we're doing that for the comfort of the
public we're looking for
cooperation from the public it's not to
inconvenience anyone and we don't think
that it will be
you might also see an enhanced presence
at logan airport as well
that's not for any particular reason
again other than to solicit cooperation
from the public
and seek out tips or or information the
last thing i want to say is there has to
be
hundreds if not thousands of photographs
or videos
or observations that were made down at
that finish line yesterday
and they're sitting out there amongst
everyone that's watching this
event this morning and i would encourage
you
to bring forward anything you might not
think it's significant but it might have
some value to this investigation
the mayor's giving you tip lines there
are plenty of those the fbi has them as
well
if you call in i assure you that someone
will follow up on your photographs or
videos that you want to submit
for consideration thank you very much
good morning my name is daniel conley
i'm the district attorney here in boston
what what occurred yesterday in boston
was an act of cowardice
while there will be an opportunity in
the future at the conclusion of this
investigation to officially define this
act
make no mistake an act of cowardice and
of this severity
cannot be justified or explained it can
only be answered
to that end some of the finest
investigators at the local
state and federal levels have been
working
through the night to not only conduct
interviews and process the scene
but to ensure that those interviews are
legally sound
and that the evidence is recovered with
the greatest care
at the same time police and other law
enforcement agencies have been actively
working
to ensure the safety of our city
at this point the loss that we have
suffered is enormous
but thanks to the efforts of emts police
officers firefighters
volunteers ordinary citizens and of
course doctors
nurses and the medical staff at boston's
world-class hospitals
we can say with absolute certainty that
more lives were saved
for this we can all give thanks
in the days and the weeks to come we
will do our very best to keep the public
and the media apprised and advised of
the progress of this investigation in
our work
it is important however for the sake of
the victims and of this city
that our investigators be given the room
to do their
jobs so that the truth can be found and
so that justice can be served
moments like this and our response to
them
define who we are in the past 24 hours
this city of boston
has shown its strength its compassion
and its determination to see justice
done
thank you dan we're happy to take
questions we will
we're going to try to take as many
questions as you have um
so maybe we'll just go from side to side
if that's uh
that yeah
well more than the evidence is the
extraordinary cooperation among these
law enforcement agencies is the mayor
and others have uh have said
at the federal state and local level
and indeed from the region we have an
unprecedented level
of law enforcement uh support and
engagement here and they are working
very very well
and very seamlessly with each other
under the leadership of the fbi and that
gives me
a lot of comfort it should give the the
public comfort as well
over here process so far that helps you
understand uh something maybe from the
materials that helps you understand the
um the level of complexity of the device
itself the level of sophistication for
the origin of the materials that would
help to understand what the
of the domestic source or international
i think i think i know what you're
getting at let me let me turn it over to
rick who i think is going to not comment
thank you governor i can't comment on on
that aspect of that what i think is
important to say
what i would like to on behalf of the
boston jttf here today
is say that there is no known imminent
physical threat
at any location where we are conducting
and might be conducting investigative
activity right now
i want to put that out to the american
public to the citizens of the city of
boston in the commonwealth of
massachusetts
anything about the nature of the devices
no i'm not going to say who is who might
or might not be in custody right now
from ocean avenue and is looking
or has found a second person who is a
roommate in that unit
and david what i can say is ice is a key
component of our boston joint terrorism
task force they are active with us right
now
and are interviewing witnesses with us
and assisting us uh
integrally with this investigation
well we are processing a lot of
photographic digital photographic
evidence right now as we
as several speakers have said today
including the governor we encourage the
continued submission of any photographic
evidence that could lead to lead value
but i can't specif i can't comment on
the
on on specific tips or leads right now
can you tell us about the surveillance
cameras in the area
are you able to use those and how they
are helpful and anything about
what you are seeing on them karen i
think commissioner davis can probably
speak best about surveillance cameras in
the area again i think we're processing
all the digital photographic evidence
that we possibly can right now as
quickly as possible with resources
from fbi headquarters in quantico and
that is a priority of the investigation
right now but i'd let commissioner davis
speak about the
video cameras
thank you rick it's a basic
investigative protocol at this point in
time for us to secure
all the video that's in the area so even
as we were removing victims
yesterday officers were assigned to go
into the
local establishments and secure those
videos
there are a large number of them so
there's a logistics issue right now
we are working with the fbi they're
sending special teams
to process that information it's our
intention to go through every frame
of every video that we have to determine
exactly who was in the area this is
probably one of the most well
photographed areas
in the country yesterday
obviously it's very difficult to move
around copley square are you asking
people to stay away
is that the best recommendation or do
you want people to come and go
we want people to come and go we want
you to live your life we want you to be
vigilant
there's there's no reason to to not come
into the city
but we do have a threat and and we are
working diligently to try to
reduce that threat we want you to to to
go about your business
give us a little room in the copley
square area be patient with us there
as we process this scene but we are
trying to turn it back to the businesses
into the community as quickly as as we
can after that evidence is collected
what do you want people to look for what
should they if i'm going through well
that's a good question actually
that's a good question what we would
like is uh forwarding any photos that
you have
around the time of the blast and
particularly in that area
but also tell us what time those photos
were taken
okay so we don't have to go through the
electronic signatures we have some data
as to when these photos were taken
naturally photos taken closer to the
blast just before
just after those are going to be
critical and we're going to try to
prioritize those
but it would give us the photos and as
much information that can help the
investigators
move forward
as part of the preparation that the
devices explode in trash cans and
there's no evidence of that there's no
evidence
there is an eod sweep that was done
there were two of them done that morning
one was done early in the morning
and the second one was done an hour
before the first runners came across
those two eod sweeps did not turn up any
evidence
but because there is unrestricted access
to the race course
simply because it's 28 miles long uh
people can come and go and and bring
items in and
three people who out confirmed to be
dead are they all
thought to be victims or would one
perhaps be
the perpetrator or one of the
perpetrators they're all victims as far
as i know
i'm sorry
no no we don't have any information on
that can you give us an idea
can you give us an idea of the breakdown
of the impact of the two separate bombs
in terms of casualties just numbers
we we have a number of 176 casualties
that
that uh presented at area hospitals
that's including hospitals on the south
shore so not just in boston
176 is the best number i have right now
17 of those individuals are critical at
this point in time
three fatalities sorry
in terms of the two moments though
no one's in custody right no one's in
custody
uh
as an ongoing investigation our
investigation certainly will not be
confined
very likely to the city limits of boston
it would extend out
to the eastern massachusetts area this
will be a worldwide investigation we
will take go
where the evidence and the leads take us
we will go to the ends of the earth
to identify the subject or subjects who
are responsible for this uh
despicable crime and we will do
everything we can to bring them to
justice
i can't comment on on that aspect of the
investigation right now certainly we
will are we are
using the full capacities of the fbi to
its fullest worldwide extent i think the
best way i can address that question is
what i previously said earlier that we
are interviewing a variety of witnesses
right now
in a variety of locations and that is
ongoing and
that is the most i can say about that
right now
again that would be commenting about
specific leads and investigative
activity that might compromise our
investigation so i really can't comment
on that right now
i would just say that we are continuing
we have multitude of resources on the
street right now the boston joint
terrorism task force
many components of which are with me on
the stage here today are out in the
street right now conducting all logical
investigation as quickly as possible
we are out in the street in a variety of
areas both in the city of boston and
outside the city of boston conducting
an investigation where the leads and
evidence take us
i was not aware of any threat
information prior to the marathon
as i mentioned earlier i'm not aware of
any physical threat information right
now from any
uh unexploded devices or any further
devices i'm not aware of any information
and to the best of my knowledge
there is no imminent physical threat
anywhere
associated with this investigation
i'd say to the folks watching us that we
have uh i
say that's resilient i see this working
together law enforcement's working on
this issue where
says it started and you know we need
cooperation for the public uh
folks out there know that something's
going on uh give it to the
fbi or the boston police whatever law
enforcement you want to give it to
there's a resilient city and we're uh i
see they'll get by this and it's a
one incident that will not mark the
city's history
the news conference from within the hour
or so in boston with the
mayor obviously there and several a
number of officials from massachusetts
and boston and the special agent in
charge
here on c-span we are expecting to take
you live to the white house in about 10